واظهرت صور تداولتها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي جنودا من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهم يحتجزون عددا من الشبان
الفلسطينيين وهم مكبلون ومعصب الاعين داخل
احد المنازل ويظهر الفيديو تعامل جنود
الاحتلال بطريقه استفزازيه مع
المعتقلين لمتابعه معنا الامين الخليل
مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار اذا ما يزال
التصعيد ايضا مستمر في الضفه ال الغربيه
ومنها وعلى وجه الخصوص الخليل نقف معك عند
ابرز
التطورات نعم ازدهار بالفعل يعني محافظات
الضفه الغربيه تشهد بشكل مستمر ومتواصل
حملات والمداهمات والاقتحامات تبدا من
الخليل حيث نحن نتواجد انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال بصباح هذا اليوم من بل ت بتمر
شمال الخليل بعد ان داهمت منازل لمواطنين
من عائله العلامه فتشت هذه المنازل وخلفت
خرابا كبيرا فيها وايضا اجرت حفريات خارج
هذه المنازل وكان هناك ايضا عمليه تفجيرات
سمعت خارج المنزل خلال عمليه المداهمه
قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت طفل يبلغ من العمر
15 عاما من هذه البيوت وهذه المنازل بعد
عمليه المداهمه التي شهدتها بلده بتمر
شمال الخليل المشهد لم يختلف كثير
في الظاهريه جنوب الخليل قوات الاحتلال
داهمت المدينه وفتشت عدد من منازل
المواطنين خلفت خرابا كبيرا فيها وصادرت
عدد من مركبات المواطنين في الظهريه جنوب
الخليل كما اقتحمت
منطقه جبل ابو رمان وداهمت عدد من البيوت
والمنازل وفتشتها ايضا في رام الله وصدفت
الغربيه قوات الاحتلال داهمت قريتي بدرس و
قبيا وسيرت دورياتها في القريتين وفتشت
عدد من بيوت المنازل من البيوت والمنازل
طبعا في القريتين كما ايضا كان هناك
مداهمه لجنوب وشرق نابلس اندلعت مواجهات
طبعا شمال الضفه الغربيه اندلعت مواجهات
بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال خلال عمليه
المداهمه فتشت عدد من البيوت والمنازل
الابرز في الضفه الغربيه هو انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال من مخيم طول كرم شمال الضفه
الغربيه بعد 46 ساعه من عمليه مداهمه
واقتحام كانت متواصله لمخيم هذه العمليه
خلفت ث
شهداء في حصيله نهائيه خلال الاقتحام
للمخيم كما كان هناك ايضا عدد كبير من
المعتقلين الذين قامت قوات الاحتلال
بتعصيب اعينهم وبتك ايديهم وباجراء
استجواب وتحقيق ميداني مع ابناء المخيم
افرج عن عدد كبير من هؤلاء فيما بقي اخرون
رهن الاعتقال عدد المعتقلين فيطول كرم ما
بعد السابع من اكتوبر وصل الى 400 معتقل
الاقتحام الذي شهده مخيم طولكرم كان هو
الاض خم والاكبر خلال الفتره القليله
الماضيه نحن نتحدث كذلك ازدهار ايضا عن
تدمير للبونى التحتيه خلال اقتحام مخيم
طول كرم وهذا ما يجري مؤخرا في كل
الاقتحامات التي يشنها الاحتلال بحق
المخيمات تحديدا وشمال الضفه الغربيه مخيم
جنين مخيم طولكرم ونور شمس ومخيم بلاطه
وغيرها من المناطق التي ترافق قوات
الاحتلال جرافات ضخمه وكبيره تقوم بعمليه
تدمير للبنى التحتيه في هذه المخيمات عدد
الشهداء في الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر من العام الماضي بلغ حتى هذه
اللحظه
368 شهيدا 48 من هؤلاء الشهداء منذ بدايه
هذا العام فقط كما تجاوز عدد المعتقلين ال
6000 معتقل منذ السابع من اكتوبر من العام
الماضي ايضا بدايه هذه الحرب وجزء كبير من
هؤلاء المعتقلين يحولوا للاعتقال الاداري
وتنكل قوات الاحتلال بهم وتتعامل معهم
بطريقه على الاقل بحسب مؤسسات حقوق
الانسان والمؤسسات المختصه بشؤون الاسرى
تشير وتقول الى ان معاناه كبيره يعانيها
الاسرى داخل سجون الاحتلال وتحديدا ما بعد
السابع من اكتوبر اذا نحن نتحدث عن تصعيد
مستمر ومتواصل في الضفه الغربيه اقتحامات
في وضح النهار وفي الليل ايضا حملات
اعتقالات مستمره ومتواصله وباعداد كبيره
وعدد شهداء مرتفع هذا كله يدلل بالفعل على
ان جبهه الضفه الغربيه بالفعل هي تشهد
توترا مستمرا ومتواصلا وعلى الاقل
المعطيات تشير الى ان هذا التصعيد مستمر
شكرا جزيلا لك من الخليل مراسل الجزيره
منتصر نصار